If you want to find out how you can get a
pass to Halloween Horror Nights at Universal,
stick around to the end of this video for
details.
One of reasons we find The Shining so disturbing
is the psychological horror and mind games,
that director Stanley Kubrick plays on us.
If Universal can employ similar tactics for
it’s upcoming The Shining attraction at
Halloween Horror Nights, it’s going to be
a success.
This starts with the layout of the hotel.
In the movie, Kubrick subconsciously drives
the viewers crazy with impossible windows
and doors, hallways that shouldn’t be there,
nonsensical dead ends, and changing corridors.
Obviously this won’t be possible, because
it’s going to be a physical location that
we get to walk through as opposed to a movie
that takes advantage of the power of editing,
but they could still use the fact that this
is a temporary set to their advantage.
In previous Horror Nights walkthroughs, we
see different movie locations connected by
using dark areas and fog as transitions.
Instead of that, we think they could use optical
illusion matte paintings to make some hallways
look deeper than they actually are.
Then we can take a turn into a room, and when
we come out, we’ll be in another location.
This will be disorienting to guests and make
it feel like you are wandering through a maze.
As we wander through these winding hallways,
they can take advantage of open doors to show
off iconic scenes, like where Wendy turns
to see the bear blowjob thing and a variety
of hotel guests in different rooms that stare
at us.
This would be an excellent way to have the
bloody elevator scene from down a hallway
and allow blood to gush at us.
It would have to be contained behind a form
of plexiglass with a drain system so it could
reset.
There are a few rooms we don't just want to
see from a distance, like Room 237, The Gold
Room, The Colorado Lounge and the Torrance
room.
If I don’t get to walk on that iconic carpet
pattern, then the whole thing is failure.
The biggest problem these locations pose is
that they are either wide open locations or
dead ends.
Most of the haunted houses at Universal contain
skinny corridors with one set path for guests
to walk on.
Wide open locations such as the Gold Room
and Colorado Lounge could make use of furniture
arrangements and possibly velvet rope to guide
people along a certain path.
Dead end areas like the Torrence room could
make use of breakaway walls that open a new
path.
For example, imagine you are being chased
by Jack Torrence through the apartment.
You are led into the bathroom and Wendy shuts
the door behind you.
Jack bangs on the door, says Here’s Johnny,
and then Wendy opens the window, allowing
guests to access a slide or ramp through the
snow to get down to safety.
This scenario puts the theme park guests in
the shoes of Danny, which we think is the
most frightening way to experience the classic
scenes.
The maze would have to start around the climax
of the story, where Jack begins to chase Danny
around the hotel.
This allows the guests to be chased through
the entire attraction to find their escape.
Being able to hear Jack yelling as they make
their escape can build tension while allowing
Jack to occasionally finds us during our quest.
Some rooms can appear larger than us to give
off the feel that we are in the mind of a
child and play on having little control over
the situations we’re placed in.
Placing the Grady Twins in our path as a blockade
would assist in keeping everyone on track.
The only friendly faces would be Wendy and
Dick Hallorann as they guide us.
Another major theme in the movie is mirrorism.
In addition to all of the symmetrical sets
and shots in the movie, mirrors are literally
used to look into the hotel’s past.
In fact, all of Jack's encounters with the
ghosts of the Overlook take place in front
of mirrors, providing a Shining reflection
into times gone by.
I have actually theorized that Jack literally
sees these figures through mirrors.
Take this scene, where Jack is getting more
worked up with each mirror that he passes.
Or this scene, where Jack seems to be looking
past Delbert Grady and conversing with his
reflection.
As it turns out, the theme park industry has
found some pretty cool uses for mirrors though
the use of digital overlays.
Remember the hitchhiking ghosts from the Haunted
Mansion?
Imagine a similar effect while you are are
traversing the depths of Room 237.
You are approached by a beautiful woman, and
turn to the mirror to find she is not as she
appears.
The digital mirror overlays aren’t the only
technology that we can see working to the
advantage of this maze.
Last year we visited a Universal walk-through
based on the Christmas horror movie, Krampus
that used temperature controlled rooms to
give theme park guests a chill, (pun intended),
when they walked into areas that are supposed
to be like an outdoor segment.
This change in temperature physically heightens
our senses and puts us more on edge, making
any scares that take place in these areas
have that much greater of an effect on us.
That leads us to how we want the attraction
to end.
The only way to do it is to chase patrons
into the hedge maze.
All of the walk-throughs you usually see at
Halloween Horror Nights are typically referred
to as mazes, despite the fact that there is
only one route you can take through the entire
thing in most cases.
Having an actual maze creates a problem for
the park though, which is that people trying
to find their way takes time, and slows down
the already extremely long lines.
Instead of having one path, we think it should
split into a few possible outcomes, each to
their own exit.
This would give people a reason to go back
through to try out the different paths and
allow a unique experience every time.
Doing this also means you would hear the screams
and terror from other guests and be unsure
if Jack was around the next turn.
Splitting it into a few possible exits, will
also provide relief to the slow flow of foot
traffic that keeps the lines from moving quickly.
And once guests do finally make it out of
that maze, I can think of no better final
image to walk away from than the realistic
sculpture of Jack Nicholson frozen in the
snow at the end of the movie.
That covers what we do want to see.
We also want to cover a few cliches that we
don’t want to see.
The Shining does have some great jump scares,
and I know they’ll do a great job of realizing
those in the form of a haunted house, but
I hope they don’t resort to unnecessary
things that don’t fit the tone of The Shining,
like people jumping out of paintings or corpses
coming to life or anything like that.
I hope they don’t have the characters unnessarily
over-zombified, as we often see in these kinds
of things.
And finally, the psychological terror of Shining
comes from what you don’t see moving, not
what you do see moving.
Any kind of floating chairs or dancing hedge
animals can be left out of this one.
OK…
Remember at the beginning of this video how
we mentioned the details of how you can get
a pass to Halloween Horror Nights?
Well, we can’t actually provide you with
one, because we’re just some people who
made this video for fun, but you can always
go online and buy one yourself--
Wait!
You can’t promise them stuff you don’t
have!
This is how the hate comments appear!
What?
It was funny though--
Funny for you!
I thought you had a pass sitting in the drawer,
but nooo when I checked, there wasn’t one!
Well, whatever, the YouTube comments are usually
pretty good at taking a joke right?
*dead silence*
AHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAH--
I know this was something new for us, so if
you are interested in content like this let
us know in this poll right here.
Also comment what you want to see in this
Shining maze, or any Halloween attractions
you’d like to see this year in general.
If you’re new to this channel, my name is
CZ and I apparently don’t know how to pronounce
the word “crayon”.
And I am Cynder, and I need to practice saying
Halloran 30,000 times.
Cynder: Dick Hollowrann.
CZ: Hallorann.
Cynder: Hallorann.
Dick Hollowrann.
CZ: Hallorann.
Cynder: Hellorann.
CZ: Hal-oh-ran.
Cynder: Hallo.Dick Hollowran.
CZ: Nooo.
Hal.
Cynder: Hol.
CZ: Hal.
Cynder: Hal.
CZ: Oh.
Cynder: Oh.
CZ: Ran.
Cynder: Ran.
Hallorann.
CZ: Yeah.
Cynder: Dick Hollowrenn as they guide us.
CZ: You didn’t change it.
Cynder: Hollowrann.
CZ: Hallorann.
Cynder: Hellorenn.
CZ: Ha.
Cynder: Ha.
CZ: Low-Ran.
Cynder: Low-Ren.
Cynder: Low Ran.
Dick Hallorann as they guide us.
CZ: Do it one more time.
Cynder: UHGH!
Dick Hallorann as they guide us.
Did I get it?
CZ: That was pretty close.
Cynder: You know what, Mr. Perfectionist?
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors, every week, ring that death bell
for notifications and we’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.